I am here with the Fantastic
understatement of the world Kate bosberg
so happy to be with you so looking this
is so fun today I want to stay here all
day I know
um well I would love to play a game with
you called three to go so we can just
get a little like insight wisdomy into
your recommendations okay all right all
right three to go
yeah I love this
um okay number one of the three a move
to bust out a dance move on the Dance
Floor I'm a terrible dancer you have to
show me your moves I really am
um you showed me a move okay I mean it
depends I definitely like this
hi
I'm not sorry
[Applause]
I really put that in your face
please use that angle
um for some reason that is I just like
you know I'm just like cool about it I
try to be I'm not I love the like
shoulders it's a little shimmy it's a
little shimmy and that says so much
about us of course on like circular but
well it's more like I'm shy no it's not
that I'm cool I'm like how what can I
get away with on the on the shy away
shoulders next time I dance it's
literally my go-to movie like it's the
cape
um okay just be petrified then you'll do
it uh I will never forget the quote that
you just taught me that we hold on the
tightest before we let go so thank you
do you have any other quotes lately that
you've heard I really liked this one
that um again I mean you'll hear me talk
about Glenn and Doyle a lot because I I
just think she's such a like courageous
Warrior
um I I loved she she said something
recently on her podcast where
um it I think it had to do with her
sister's divorce and the wise the whys
are hard sometimes like why does
something happen you know and the desire
to get an answer to something that
you'll probably never get an answer to
and Glennon said sometimes you have to
just sink into the mystery
and like that helps me to let go because
you know it's it's it's hard for me to
let something go I think just think
think into the mystery like just sink
into the mystery and enjoy the ride no
matter what part of the human experience
you're at thank you I should we shall
take that with us as well
the third question that's the best thing
to bring to the beach
um I would say a really great tote bag
because otherwise you're like carrying
all your stuff
um or a really really good hat I love
that thank you Kate Bosworth Dive Into
Summer Sun and get that beach boost with
Kate's incredible fashion collection
with Roxy it is so awesome first of all
I'm such a Roxy girl and in the
anniversary of Blue Crush you guys are
doing this awesome collab and it
couldn't be more cute and more delicious
and it's available at roxy.com and
select stores worldwide we will be right
back
[Music]
foreign